>> Okay, well, thanks everyone, for coming
to an authors at Google talk today.
I know the weather was kind of iffy.
So thank you, Mr. Thomson, for making it all
the way from San Francisco.
We have a very special treat today.
David Thomson is a San Francisco-based film
critic and historian and the author of more
than twenty books, including the new biographical
Dictionary of Film.
Regarded as one of the best reference works
on the cinema and it's in its fourth edition.
He was born in World War II-era London, when
movies like Red River, The Third Man, and
Susan Cain first ignited his passion for film
as a child.
Today, he'll talk about his latest series
called 'Great Stars' where he examines the
back stories of Humphrey Bogart, Ingrid Bergman,
Bette Davis, and Gary Cooper and the films
that made them legendary.
Please give a hand for David Thomson.
>> [Applause]
David: Thank you very much. Can you hear me
fine?
People like stories about movie stars.
So I will give you some stories.
There was a company named Selznick International.
Selznick International was a partnership of
David O. Selznick, who was born into the movie
business, and Jock Whitney, who was at the
time one of the wealthiest heirs in America.
And one of the first things they did in 1935
when they made their company was, they bought
the screenrights to a novel called 'Gone with
the Wind'.
These are the people who made Gone with the
Wind, which -- no matter what people tell
you about Avatar -- has taken more real money
than any film ever made in this country -- still.
And here's the story about what happened in
the New York offices of Selznick International.
There was a Swedish elevator operator.
And every day, he would take Kay Brown up
and down to the offices.
And Kay Brown was the chief literary talent
scout at Selznick International.
She was the person who recommended to David
that he buy Gone with the Wind, even though
he hadn't read the book.
She had a hunch it would do something.
One day, in the elevator, the operator says,
"Oh, Miss Brown, I hear from home the most
fantastic stories about this beautiful, young
girl there is in Sweden.
Her name is Ingrid Bergman.
And really, my relatives have sent me pictures
of her.
I don't know whether you can possibly get
any of her movies, but I really think you
should look at them."
And Kay Brown never discounted a hunch, even
if it came from humble sources.
She got an Ingrid Bergman film.
She looked at it -- couldn't understand a
word of it of course, but she could see that
the camera loved Ingrid Bergman.
That is not so common a thing.
And it is one of the things that people in
the picture business to this day still live
for -- to find someone like that.
So she speaks to David Selznick, and she says,
"There's this young woman in Sweden, and I
think maybe she's got something."
And Selznick says, "Well, go over to Stockholm
and see her." She's a poor Swedish girl.
She can't possibly come here.
Go over to Sweden. See her."
Kay Brown makes her way to Sweden on a boat
in the winter -- very difficult.
She gets there.
Ingrid Bergman opens the door carrying a newborn
baby -- not a good sign.
The actress has a newborn baby; there could
be conflict of interests.
But she sees straightaway that this woman
has got something amazing.
And she says to her, "Well, would you perhaps
come to Hollywood to see Mr. Selznick, because
I think he might be prepared to put you under
contract?
It could transform your life."
Ingrid says, "Well, I have a newborn baby."
And Kay Brown actually says to her, "I know,
and you know, the world is not looking good."
This is 1939.
"There's probably going to be a war.
If I were you, I'd stick with your baby and
stay in Sweden, which looks as if it might
be a safer country than other countries if
a war comes."
And Ingrid Bergman says, "Oh, no. I'll come.
I'll come."
In any event, she leaves a six-month-old baby
with the father.
You can always tell the real determination
in some stars early on.
She leaves the child, and she goes to America
-- big journey in those days -- she turns
up, carrying her suitcase, at the Selznick
house in Beverly hills.
And Mrs. Selznick is there. It's a Sunday.
And she's listening -- it's a Saturday, I
beg your pardon.
She's listening to the Kentucky Derby on the
radio.
And she just signals to Ingrid Bergman, "Wait,
wait.
Till the race is over. I want to concentrate
on the race."
And Ingrid Bergman waits, standing in the
sun with her suitcase having come 6,000 miles.
And at last, she's waved forward into the
royal presence, so to speak.
And she says, "I'm Ingrid Bergman. I've come
from Stockholm."
And Mrs. Selznick says, "Oh, yes, of course.
The trouble is, my husband is at the studio."
They worked at the studios on Saturdays in
those days.
And they would have done anyway, because he
was shooting at the time Gone with the Wind.
So Mrs. Selznick says to her, "Never mind.
I will look after you.
I'm going to a party later on today. You come
with me.
And Ingrid says, "You sure that's all right?
I shouldn't stay here and wait for Mr. Selznick?"
And Mrs. Selznick says, "We never know when
he will come back.
Just stick with me.
Sooner or later, we'll bump into him."
They go to the party. She's traveled.
She's meeting stars and celebrities at the
party.
She goes back to the Selznick house.
David Selznick has still not arrived.
She falls asleep, actually.
And someone nudges her and says, "Mr. Selznick
is here.
He's in the kitchen eating.
Hasn't eaten all day. He's been working.
He's stuffing himself with food in the kitchen."
She goes out to meet him -- the man who has
brought her all the way from Sweden.
And he looks at her, and he says, "Oh, dear.
You are too tall."
She was very tall. She was taller than David
Selznick.
And they talked for a few minutes.
And he looks at her in a sort of very professional
way.
And he says, "Your teeth need a lot of work,
and your chin is a real problem.
I can see them straight away. And I'm not
a cameraman.
And you know, 'Bergman' sounds too Germanic
a name.
We're going to have to change your name if
there's any chance of you having a career."
And this is the decisive moment.
She says, "Mr. Selznick, I think you're being
very rude.
I've come all this way to see you.
It's a long journey. I've left my daughter
behind.
Sometimes that upsets me.
And now, you make personal comments about
my appearance, about my name, about my height,
all of which you had an information before
I came here.
All of which were in photographs.
You could have saved yourself a lot of money,
a lot of time and trouble.
I needn't have come here.
I could have stayed in Stockholm.
I could be nursing my daughter."
And David says, "[snapping fingers] I got
it.
You are the tall, natural, honest, Swedish
type who will talk back to the boss.
I see a whole career."
And she says, "What do you mean? What do you
mean?"
And he says, "I see who you will be for us.
We will do nothing in the way of making you
up.
It will be a big part of your publicity campaign
that Ingrid Bergman wears no make-up.
And she says, "Well, I do wear a little make-up,
you know, I mean, most women wear a little
make-up."
He says, "You will wear no make-up at all."
[laughter]
"We will emphasize how tall you are.
You are a nordic queen, a princess.
We will concentrate on the name Ingrid Bergman,
and you will always be as you were with me
just now.
You will be candid. You will be direct. You
will tell the truth.
You will not be like American stars -- kissing
up to the press, kissing up to anyone.
And I think you can have a career.
Well, in two or three years time, she had
made Casa Blanca -- not for Selznick.
He loaned her out.
In other words, what he did was, he paid her
a holding salary, and then, loaned her out
at a much larger salary to Warner Brothers.
So he made a huge profit on it.
He did that with her a lot of the time.
And, Ingrid built a publicity image around
this true, simple, Swedish, peasant girl without
make-up, without lies.
Alas, it bore very little resemblance to the
real Ingrid Bergman.
Anyone who noticed her realized that one reason
was she had left her husband and her child
in Sweden.
They came over eventually, but one reason
why she had left them there in Sweden was
that she liked flirting with any man she met.
On almost every film she made, she had one
or two romances.
This was not unknown in Hollywood at that
time.
And you have to realize that this was a time
when, in Hollywood, the private lives of stars
could be controlled by the studios.
The press were extremely kind and generous
to this kind of thing.
With this result, that Ingrid Bergman became,
by 1946-7, No. 1 box office figure in the
world.
She had won the Oscar in Gaslight, she played
a nun in the Bells of St. Mary's with Bing
Crosby -- quite atrocious film, but a huge
box office success.
Nearly everything she made was box office
money.
And because the screen role she played was
so appealing and so charming, and because
they dovetailed so well with the publicity
that was applied to her by the studio -- in
everything from still-photo sessions to stories
that were put out for fan magazines, written
by the studios, but as if written by her -- the
whole thing fitted together.
And the public believed and would have voted
if they had been given a chance, that Ingrid
Bergman was the truest, the most natural,
the most honest of all the movie stars.
She became bored with Hollywood.
She -- you would have to read the little book
I've written about her to get all the affairs,
but they were more than the public dreamed
of.
They were habitual.
She became bored, though, with American films.
And one day, she walked into a theater in
Los Angeles, and she saw a film called 'Rome,
Open City,' directed by Roberto Rossellini,
one of the first, Italian, near-realist films
-- a film actually made while the Germans
were in Italy.
A film made with great difficulty and a raw,
naturalistic, realistic film.
And she loved it.
The young Anna Magnani had a lead part in
the film, and she wanted to be like that Anna
Magnani.
And she wrote a letter to Roberto Rossellini
saying, "If you could use a Swedish actress
who can only say 'I love you' in Italian -- it's
the only words of Italian I know, I am at
your disposal."
Well, Roberto Rossellini -- a scoundrel, great
director, and a scoundrel -- was living to
come to Hollywood.
He gets this letter.
He thinks, "My chance! Ingrid Bergman, the
biggest star in the world.
If I make friends with her, I find the right
script for her.
I go to Hollywood. I become world-famous director."
Ingrid Bergman was dying to go to Europe.
"Ah, I could make a real, true, political,
radical, tough film.
Not this sentimental crap that I'm making
in Hollywood, pretending I'm a nun with Bing
Crosby singing to the children."
Appalling stuff. She ends up having to make
the journey.
She goes to Italy.
She starts to make a film with him called
Stromboli, about a refugee who goes to live
on the volcanic island of Stromboli in the
Mediterranean.
And not surprisingly, they've developed an
affair.
This affair -- because it's in Europe, outside
studio control -- hits the press.
The world goes mad as if it were the O.J.
Simpson case.
You have to read the documents of the time
to understand the outrage.
Ingrid was condemned on the floor of the Senate.
She was condemned from pulpits all across
America.
People sent in their signed photographs of
her, torn to pieces, in demonstration of how
shocked they were.
And suddenly, she became box office poison.
She did not work in America for six or seven
years.
She had to live in Europe, in Italy, with
Rossellini, having three more children -- one
of whom you know, Isabella Rossellini, making
a number of very interesting films that never
did anything at the box office.
And she was only allowed to come back to America
to make a film called 'Anastasia', for which
she won her second Oscar.
But her whole career -- I'm trying to show
you -- was premised upon public image.
And the whole thing was there from the beginning.
Selznick says, "You're pure. You're wonderful.
You're true."
She says, "Well, I'm not really -- not at
all."
But they make her that, and it makes her for
a few years, and then, it destroys her.
One story.
We're going to have time for two of these
good stories.
Humphrey Bogart.
Of the four people I've written about, Humphrey
Bogart was the only one who was remotely upper
class -- came from a good family, a moneyed
family.
His mother was an illustrator for popular
magazines, and she used young Humphrey as
her model.
And Bogart goes on the stage, and nobody can
place him.
They try to place him as a young, romantic
lead, because he looks quite good.
But he doesn't smile very well.
And he looks sour, and he has a scowl.
So by the time he goes to Hollywood, he's
a villain.
And Bogey started making films in 1935.
And he was a villain for seven or eight years
-- not a star.
The stars at Warner Brothers -- his studio,
in that time -- were Jimmy Cagney, George
Raft, Elmer G Robinson, later Errol Flynn.
He played supporting parts.
He's the gangster whom Cagney kills at the
end.
And his career was not taking.
He became a drunk because of that.
He went through three marriages.
He was an extremely difficult, unpleasant,
needling guy.
And he blamed his agents.
He said, "You can't get the right kind of
part for me."
And they would say, "Well, Bogey, what is
the right kind of part for you?"
And he said, "I don't know. I'm just an actor."
And actors never know what the right parts
for them are.
There may be some exceptions, but on the whole,
they never know what the right parts for them
are.
And Bogart goes on and on.
Until one day, he runs across a man -- a young
man, screenwriter named John Huston.
And Huston is working on a gangster film about
an elderly gangster, a veteran, who's let
out of jail and goes on the run, is killed
in the end, but is a gangster who is sympathetic.
And Huston says, "You know, it's sort of a
quality Bogart's got.
Bogart's nasty, but you sort of know Bogart
wants to be liked."
And they put him in a film called High Sierra,
1941, and it begins to happen.
Bogart relaxes, because he knows that the
script likes his character.
He treats people badly in the film -- he kills
people and so on and so forth, but film is
on his side.
Straight away, Huston, who wants to direct,
takes him up and puts him in a film called
The Maltese Falcon, playing a private eye
named Sam Spade who behaves like a gangster.
And you have this image building -- Bogart's
really not aware of it -- of a new kind of
guy, tough, hard-boiled, mean, sarcastic,
needling other people, goading other people,
but instead of the audience disapproving of
him, which had happened all through the '30s,
they sort of start saying, "Don't you like
Bogart when he's like that?
When he really puts it to the woman?
When he really tells Mary Astor what a shit
she is in The Maltese Falcon?
Don't you think Bogart's never been better?"
And this turns into the Humphrey Bogart that
you all know.
And it reaches its sort of epitome in films
like Casa Blanca, again.
One film that figures in the career of both
people.
To Have and Have Not, and The Big Sleep.
And all of a sudden, Bogart is established.
And as if you never have the courage to believe
in magic, this man who has had a disastrous
series of marriages, in one of these films,
To Have and Have Not, finds himself playing
opposite a girl of nineteen.
She acts about 92, but she was 19, who had
never made a film before, whose name was Betty
Perske.
But she would be called Lauren Bacall by the
time the film comes out.
And he finds he's falling in love with her
in front of the camera.
And she falls in love with him.
And they become the union that is still, I
think, probably the most romantic, smoke-enshrouded
coupling that Hollywood ever put together.
I cannot tell you that either one of them
was totally faithful to the other through
the short years of their marriage, because
Bogart was dead by 1957, but still, it was
an extraordinary union and marriage.
And it made Bogart a star when his career,
in fact, was about two-thirds over.
So those are the two stories that I have time
to tell you that show you what a very strange
business stardom can be.
And how, as a rule, the people who are the
stars have no control over it.
Sometimes there are other people off to one
side who have some control over it.
You can make a star if you're lucky and you
know what you're doing, but the stars themselves,
rarely have the authority.
But, once you've got a persona that the public
will buy, you're hung.
It works in the media still, to this day.
No one really knows -- I would argue -- who
Johnny Carson was, or who David Letterman
is.
They're both, I think, deeply mysterious people
who can survive going on television, so to
speak, every night week after week.
But they have a charm with the camera.
If you ask them to define it, I know they
couldn't do it.
It's all they can do to go on and, three nights
out of five, make it work.
Now, a lot of stardom -- and the thing we
call 'stardom' -- which still makes the movies
function to a great degree -- has to do with
this extraordinary relationship some people
have -- if the dialogue is right, if the lighting
is right -- the relationship they have with
the camera.
I'm sorry to rush it, but there was a slight
misunderstanding over timing.
If I'm not back in the city by 3:00, my wife
will kill me.
So I have to be there, but I'm so glad you
came out.
I'm delighted to have met you.
And we've got 10 minutes, certainly, for some
questions or comments if anyone would like
to.
Q Hello. I can just ask it.
I'm curious if you believe that stars such
as Bogey and Ingrid Bergman would still be
considered -- or would still have the opportunities
and the chance -- like, fortune -- that they
had back then, if they would still have now?
Because I know there's different acting methods
and you watch them now -- there's a certain
charm to their whole style of acting.
I'm curious how that would fit in with movies
of today?
A I think stardom lasts a very short time
now.
You know, a lot of the people I've written
about in this series, are people who had really
long careers -- 30, 40-year careers nearly
-- that is extremely hard to see in today's
light.
And I think the kids who do become famous
know it.
And they take great advantage of their fame
as quickly as they can.
They cash in. It's very difficult to sustain
a career like that.
The other thing is, you must remember, all
of these people worked for studios.
They worked for the house -- for the publishing
house.
And there were six writers at Warner Brothers,
let's say, employed full-time as screenwriters.
And one of their chief tasks would be a Bette
Davis picture, or a Bogart picture.
And of course, the writers know the types
they're working for.
They know the kind of film Bette Davis appears
in where Bette challenges men as really no
one else did on the screen in those days.
So they look for parts like that, for roles
like that.
And then, when they start to make the film,
you go on set, and Bogart sees the photographer,
Sid Peacock, let's say, who has photographed
him six times already.
In other words, he knows how you photograph
Bogart.
So that -- the costume department knows how
you dress him, so the backup that went with
the stars, the support system, which includes
people in the publicity department who knew
how to hush up certain stories, was enormously
kind to the stars.
Because a star career, once you had undertaken
it, was a thing a studio cherished.
They had you under contract for seven years.
Essentially, a lot of stars made most of their
films for one or two studios.
So, you cultivated them, you built them, and
you kept them going a long, long time.
The studios don't exist like that anymore.
There are no long-term contracts, you know.
Every film is made up on a one-off contract.
So nobody thinks of the future. Nobody really
builds careers.
And the young people who've got something
-- and there are plenty of young people who
have got talent -- they are told, "Cash in
as quickly as you can."
So you see careers that go up very fast, right
away.
And maybe then vanish after ten years, or
five years, even.
So no, I don't think it's the same kind of
thing at all.
Television is still kinder to stars.
It perseveres with them -- keeps them -- but
not the movies.
Q Thank you. A much shorter question, which
I'd love for you to delve more into is, "Which
is your favorite film of 2009?"
A 2009?
Q I would say this year, but there's only
been like a month, so last year.
A The film I would really look forward to
seeing again was the Coen Brothers', "A Serious
Man."
I thought that was so funny, and I loved it.
I'm not sure it's intended to be as funny
as I thought it was. [laughter]
I loved it. Loved that one very much.
Yes, sir.
Q Just following up on one of your comments
from your previous question.
It's true that there are fewer careers nowadays
where you can star -- we can point to those
people of the last, even 30 years who have
built up very strong careers.
Two that come to mind are like, Christopher
Walken, Michael Caine who have been in the
film industry for ages.
So I guess my question is, from this perspective
that stars last for less time, does that mean
that people can't be?
A Michael Caine and Christopher Walken, if
they were here, and I've talked to both of
them -- would tell you, "I'm a character actor.
I've lasted because I play supporting parts."
Now, occasionally, they have played leading
parts -- it's true -- and I don't wish to
disparage their ability at all.
But they really have survived as long as they
have, because they play supporting parts.
The supporting actor is a quite different
phenomenon.
Q Okay.
A They earn far less, obviously.
And they probably go on forever, all their
lives.
Yes, yes. And we have a very rich crop of
them at the moment.
Yeah, yeah. Johnny Depp is a star.
Johnny Depp made a film last year, Public
Enemies -- hugely promoted when it came out.
Not being talked about in the Oscars at all.
Johnny Depp is a star who's not -- he's never
found that one, big, knockout picture that
will make him forever.
He may find it; he may not, I don't know.
Q The other actor I can think around perhaps
is Robert Downey Jr. whose career sort of
survived a seven-year hiatus.
A Robert Downey Jr. is a very interesting
figure, yeah.
Q So, I don't know if you can really state
any other careers that could possibly be?
A I think he's a character actor in the end.
But he's a very smart, interesting guy who
married very well.
He was making a great mess of his life, and
I don't know whether you saw him on the Golden
Globes, but that woman who is next to him,
she has revised his career totally.
Q Very good. Thank you.
Q I don't want to keep listing actors for
the remaining five minutes, but since no one
has a question, along the same line, I would
think of Harrison Ford or Sean Connery or
Denzel Washington.
A I think they are all stars -- I would agree.
I mean, you know, clearly they -- all except
Denzel -- have faded away now.
Connery has become a veteran.
He's nearly retired.
Harrison Ford talks about being retired.
Harrison Ford -- there was a period in his
life -- ended about 15 years ago, I'd say
-- where he probably had made more money
-- his films had grossed more money -- than
any other actor who's ever been.
And he was an authentic star. Connery was
a great star too.
And James Bond made Connery.
There would not have been anything but for
that I think.
Yeah.
Q This is falling out pretty much on part
of the answer to your first question about
the differences because we don't have the
studio system anymore.
And one of the things you also said was that
stars themselves don't really have much sense
of what it is that is their thing that could
carry them on.
But are those actors more responsible for
their own careers these days, or is that not
true?
A Oh, absolutely. Once upon a time, actors
were told what parts to play by the studio.
In the Bette Davis story I've told, she went
to London to break her contract.
And Warner Brothers took her to court in London,
and she had to come back.
And she had to fulfill her contract.
And she was like many stars of that period;
she had no option about what she did.
She searched for material herself and recommended
it to the studio, but there was no guarantee
that they would do that.
Nowadays, every star has a little entourage
of people who read material for them and advise
them and suggest what they do.
And that entourage has to be paid for out
of the star's salary.
It's a big reason why stars get as much money
as they do.
And generally -- I've been in on some of those
conversations -- generally, the advice the
entourage give is appalling, you know, really
appalling.
And stars are not, on the whole, very good
at choosing.
Q So does that mean we should expect there
to be fewer, or?
A Yes.
Q It's more chancy -- more calculated?
A There's still thousands of people who want
to get into the movies.
And they are ready to replace everyone.
You know, someone looks as if they've got
a great career ahead of them.
The only actress in America in modern times
who has really gone beyond youthfulness -- and
the end line for youthfulness, ladies, I hate
to tell you this -- it used to be forty -- the
only one who's done it is Meryl Streep.
And if you saw Meryl Streep on the Golden
Globes, you saw her confession about what
a hard life it is being her, you know.
Now, Katharine Hepburn, Bette Davis, Barbara
Stanwyck, once upon a time, many others -- went
way beyond that.
Very hard to do it today.
Q Is it possible that part of the replacing
of actors -- stars -- is done by directors
becoming stars?
A Yes.
Q It's a time where directors are really perhaps
like taking?
A Directors are the stars.
And directors love to make stars.
So that, for instance, if you're a director
-- here's an option -- you've got a part.
Little uncertain about how all the women is
in the film.
Let's suppose the choice comes down to Nicole
Kidman, who wants 15 million for it.
And you can just about come out 15 million
still.
Or this kid you saw doing a play at Yale will
do it.
She'd do it for nothing.
It has a huge effect on the economy of pictures.
That's why you get so many newcomers coming
into the movies.
They're more malleable. They'll do as they're
told.
And they're giving you a gift on the budget
straightaway that is enormously important.
So yes.
Q But they are increasing the risk as well.
A I'm not sure they are.
I'm not sure, for instance, that the public
hasn't seen Nicole Kidman and what she has
done to her face enough.
And if the young woman they've got is beautiful
enough, and she's good enough, and there's
a load of talent around, you know.
I'm not sure that that's not the best way
to go.
So I think you're going to see kids, you know,
I mean, the young woman who's in on education
-- Carey Mulligan, who will certainly be
up for the Oscar -- a film worth seeing if
you haven't seen it.
She probably did that film for, I don't know,
20,000 pounds maybe.
Well, if you're trying to set up a movie,
that is a huge advantage.
So that's always going to count.
Can we make this the last question?
Q So, your personal opinion -- given this
great change in the landscape of the industry
-- has that affected the quality of movies?
Have they gotten better or worse or are they
just different?
A It's affected the nature of movies.
I'm a critic, and I'm 68.
So I can easily fall back on the things which
says, "Well, they don't make them the way
they used to."
They don't, but they don't intend to.
They're making a different kind of movie.
I don't like Avatar.
It doesn't matter that I don't like it; millions
of people adore it.
That may be mysterious to me.
And for me, in my position, it's worth trying
to work out why they like it.
I think we're going into a future where less
and less of the movies being made in America
are the kind of movies I'm going to like.
On the other hand, a lot of the movies being
made in independent America, and being made
in Europe, and being made in Africa and Asia,
I like more and more.
And if you are a filmgoer, this is getting
to be a pretty exciting time.
But you need to know which writers of film
to read to sort of get your recommendations,
because there's an awful lot of films coming
in.
I think the Great Age of American film -- Hollywood,
in other words -- is over.
American television, at the moment, is amply
replacing it.
American television is having a Golden Age.
Enjoy that while you can, you know.
And hunt down some of the rarer films that
are out there.
>> [Applause]